[Musique]
ils ont voulu se mettre au vert pour
quelques jours olivia et benoît viennent
de bruxelles
c'est la toute première fois qu'ils se
rendent dans le morvan des vacances au
mode camping et randonnées qu'il ne
regrette pas on avait envie de nature et
on a vu un peu quels étaient les parcs
nationaux aux alentours de la belgique
on a vu le morvan n'y avait jamais été
donc on s'est dit que ça pouvait être la
destination
on adore les jeux d'illac la nature
c'est vallonné
c'est tout ce qu'on voulait et puis il a
fait très beau donc on est content pour
le couple belge
le séjour s'arrête à quarré-les-tombes
un petit village qui attire de nouveaux
touristes comme ces charentais de
passage dans la région
ce qu'on apprécie ici donc c'est la
beauté des paysages le calme et on n'a
jamais visité la région donc on essaye
de voir ce qui se passe chez vous dans
le morvan et depuis le début du mois les
bars restaurants et hôtels du petit
village tourne à plein régime dans cet
hôtel
on refuse même du monde actuellement
l'impression d'être tous les jours déjà
sur la semaine du 15 août
donc ça fait chaud au coeur et on est
très heureux et que ça dure voilà qu'on
a jusqu'à jusqu'au 15 novembre dans cet
état d'esprit ce serait formidable
plutôt que de passer leurs vacances sur
la côte d'azur ou à l'étranger
certains touristes ont privilégié les
grands espaces loin de la foule le
morvan fait donc partie des destinations
à la mode qu'on voit principalement
cette année suite aux événements
beaucoup de français donc on va dire à
90 % de personnes françaises notamment
des départements qu'on voyait pas avant
comme le département de l'hérault des
landes de la loire atlantique
et puis on s'aperçoit aussi que ya des
parisiens qui viennent ici pour un
repérage pour éventuellement venir
s'installer là dans le morvan
l'embellie devrait durer au moins
jusqu'au 15 août